des mondiaux de piste en 2015 d europe
en 2016 le départ de paris nice depuis
2010 ou encore le tour de france le
cyclisme rythme la vie sportive
yvelinoise mais les sportifs de haut
niveau ne sont pas les seuls à profiter
des routes et chemins
aujourd'hui c'est près de 850 km plus de
600 à 850 km de pistes cyclables
développer dans le département qui nous
permet de relier à la fois tous nos
lieux culturels de relier nos villes de
relier nos espaces et puis de rendre
aussi encore une fois ce département
attractif ces départements vert on est
en train de travailler avec une et dix
aussi par exemple pour essayer de
trouver des solutions pour pouvoir
accompagner des bornes de recharge 6 sur
le vélo sur le vélo électrique une
présence de la discipline qui permet à
la fédération française de cyclisme ou
de récompenser le département 2019 les
yvelines sont reconnus terre
d'excellence du cyclisme un territoire
que se partagent 27 clubs
le vélo club et donc pour saint quentin
en yvelines recense 140 adhérents des
jeunes prometteurs et des pistards
confirmé pas vraiment d'une école de la
piste de vtt la route des cyclo cross
la prochaine étape enfin tu n'existes
pas une passion pour la petite reine qui
devrait durer au minimum jusqu'en 2024
le département accueillera les épreuves
cyclistes pour les jeux olympiques